this video is sponsored by surf shark i
have finally finished
dressrosa what an amazing ride while it
was held largely by a number of factors
stemming from both fishman island and
punk hazard i think it's safe for me to
say that dressrosa will go down as one
of the most ambitious arcs yet explored
in the one piece universe the lore it's
introduced to this series specifically
in the second half i'll be discussing
today
is nothing short of stupidly good and i
can't wait to explore it with you all
today having started off as a humble
wannabe pirate shoving off the shores of
his home windmill village luffy as this
arc demonstrated is more than on his way
and has grown up considerably this arc
is everything i wanted from a story all
rolled up in one big package but was it
as good as i thought it could have been
well let's find out i'm totally not mark
and these are my first impressions of
thoughts on and review for the brutal
the sinister
and the staggering dressrosa
now just arrived at chapter 801 the end
of dressrosa once again i find myself in
a position to praise it for not only
delivering a satisfied conclusion to the
story it was trying to tell in a smart
fashion
but i also want to at some point address
the level of setup that this arc
accomplished for
later arcs culminating in a significant
moment the likes of which i knew would
eventually be coming
but never expected it here and the means
with which this arc achieves this
is fantastically subtle utilizing one of
my favorite aspects of the shonen genre
that honestly led to a genuine surprise
for me at the end and
once again it makes complete sense but
more on that in a little bit
subtle storytelling is probably my
favorite brand of narrative creation
i love climactic battles as much as the
next guy and believe you me there are
tons of these in this part of the ark
but
if a writer can pull off subtle
developments through brief dialogue
engagements
or through environment that's totally my
jam and otis seems to be the master of
this particular technique
setting something up hundreds of
chapters prior with the express purpose
of paying it off
a literal decade later for instance
it was brought to my attention that
during a specific section of skypia
which was written in 2003 in 2004 nolan
was regaling his village with tales of
where he had been but one such tale he
mentioned
while brief was of a land of tiny people
and
if you recall i remarked in my last
video that i thought it was curious that
the civilization of tantatas
all idolized noland and when i found out
this quote from skype i made
11 years before the tantatas were even
introduced i sat back in my chair in
utter amazement
the level of patience it takes for a
writer to delay gratification for that
long
is staggering but so so worth it as the
feeling it gave me as a reader having
only covered the material of skype a few
months prior was intense so i can only
imagine what sort of euphoric endorphin
rush a decade delayed reveal like that
would have been for some of you out
there who have been reading for that
long
that on its own is crazy to think about
from a world building point of view but
would you believe that there's a much
more significant or crucial plot point
in this arc that's foreshadowed in the
most subtle way i've ever experienced in
a story
so come with me on a journey won't you
cast your minds back to the events
immediately following marineford
luffy's going through some stuff and the
world is in disarray as the navy are
just after coming away with a victory
having defeated
and killed both firefist ace and
whitebeard in this battle there's a
panel which shanks and marco as they
visit the graves of these fallen proud
pirates
and this is one of the first times we
see the grave afterwards we don't really
see it very often outside of a brief
mention or a chapter cover much much
later
and during this intermission time we are
also introduced to the character of sabo
as he
luffy and ace grow up together before
tragically being torn apart from each
other by a celestial dragon fast forward
a few hundred chapters and
boom sabo is revealed to still be alive
leading to the most wholesome reaction
from luffy i've seen yet in the series
but what's freaking amazing about this
reveal during the coliseum bout with
sabo is that it was foreshadowed if you
rewind back
100 chapters to the cover of chapter 668
in the lower corner of the panel are the
three sake cups
luffy ace and sabo shared and we knew at
that point luffy had not done that and
ace definitely didn't
had i noticed this incredibly subtle but
fantastic piece of foreshadowing it
would have been possible for me to
determine that sabo was still alive and
would show up sooner or later in a
definitive manner
and needless to say when this was
brought to my attention in a similar
fashion to the nolan world building
i didn't know what to do with this
intense sense of excitement i had for
the future of this series
from these two pieces of information
brought to my attention over the last
two days i can once again
completely understand how and why oda's
one piece has retained such an avid and
voracious reader base over the last two
decades
and quite simply because oda loves this
world more than anyone which is
something to say considering its fan
base
filling it with occasionally small and
oftentimes massive moments of passionate
storytelling as he guides us through the
lives of the wonderful inhabitants that
dwell within the sprawling oceanic
universe
he's created it might honestly sound
pretentious to say this but
i'm genuinely happy that i can say i was
reading one piece before it ended
because having that mystery hanging over
my head to enjoy is something most
people won't be able to say
because once one piece ends it'll be
over forever it's the small section of
time that it runs for
between when it starts and it ends is
the journey to enjoy
which at the end of the day i think is
worth more than any ending he can
deliver and that's by no means saying
the ending will be bad
it will most likely be amazing and
speaking of things ending this is the
arc that finally
usopp loses his secret identity but it
also is the only one where he becomes a
deity so
it's a mixed bag for sure but what makes
this funny is that for whatever reason
the usop character despite
finding himself in situations he is
utterly terrified of always seems to
come out on top and while that makes for
engaging canon mouse chase
battle scenarios for him to add to the
mix it also concocts unique conclusions
like soga king
or more recently god usa having been
branded the savior of the tantatas and
now
everyone who has transformed from a toy
into a human again
held above like some sort of god figure
through the far-reaching angel light
rays he is broadcast to the island and
the wider world as their one and only
savior
even mistakenly uttering some slurred
speech in the form of holy order
and while this is hilarious and
concludes at the end of this arc with an
equally funny revised bounty number it
makes me think back to all the popular
lies usop has told in the past and
whether or not they might eventually end
up becoming true i mean
he pretty much has an army now so who
knows
now this won't be the only time i
mentioned god usap in this video but
i think for right now we should start
hopping into the events surrounding the
conclusion of this tale
and let me tell you if the first half of
the dressrosa review was top to bottom
exposition and world building then this
second one is wall-to-wall battles with
the established set up to this section
being taken care of in the last video
the island has found all the truth
behind doflamingo's heinous plans and
thus he has to cast the entire island
into a giant cage composed of his own
string citing that each one of the
heroes have bounties on their own heads
encouraging the combatants in the city
to capture them for a reward
and their freedom from this cage
naturally god usopp gets the highest
bounty with
500 million berries but luffy isn't too
far behind
either and spawning from this there are
dozens of individual battles that take
place
all as luffy tries to reach doflamingo
all in the singular effort of clobbering
him
and freeing the country no it's not
going to be easy as he had to travel up
the different levels to reach the palace
where doflamingo is ultimately waiting
and all along the way the forces of the
straw hat crew have to contend with the
various officers of the don quixote
family
leading to honestly compelling and
really unique conflicts that offered a
lot in the way of character
it's very easy for sections of story
congested with battle sequences to get
tiring very fast
as constant unbroken action typically
speaking is a
fast track to poor pacing or even
boredom if you don't have something else
to contrast the action with
and what's rather remarkable about this
arc is that it contrasts
action with other mechanically different
action sequences to keep the pacing at a
satisfying level that i've honestly
never really experienced before
so since the last episode had a lot of
exposition to break down i thought it
might be interesting for this video that
i go through some of the most
significant battles that take place in
this section of the story and share what
i thought about them and explain how i
thought they worked so effectively
quite similarly to the alabasta arc ages
ago this arc climax focuses on all the
straw hats present taking part in
various battles against the forces of
doflamingo as luffy makes his way to the
main battle with the main man himself
doflamingo and they are all great but
very different
some offering room for lots of comedy
others more subdued and revealing while
more
are just plain old epic
and one of the first obstacles standing
in the way of luffy's path to doflamingo
is that of the colossal stone ogre man
pika towering bigger than anything any
of the straw hats have ever faced yet in
the series this devil fruit wielder
offered a very different sort of battle
and i was very excited to hear that
zorro
immediately took it on allowing luffy to
push forward and i found this battle to
be great simply because it's super easy
to understand
why he poses a threat to zorro and the
others regenerating using the stone of
his environment
and also he's friggin huge a bunch of
the enjoyment i personally gleaned from
this battle
wasn't necessarily just the one-on-one
dynamic of pika facing off against the
soon-to-be greatest swordsman in the
world
but also from zorro trying to stop him
from interfering with anyone else on
their quest around the island and up the
mountain
culminating in a series of action
sequences both gripping and engaging my
favorite being zorro's distraction of
the brute in order to allow robin
rebecca and bartolomeo the ability to
use him as a stepping stone shortcut to
get to the top and of course the climax
of this battle pika making the grave
mistake of turning his back on the swift
swordsman allowing him to utilize a
brand new technique giving him the time
to figure out on the fly by the way the
perfect strategy for taking on an enemy
that can regenerate
it's smart it's epic and it has a shot
of zoro cutting through someone that
looks like he's the size of a country
it's awesome oh also it came with this
interesting piece of information that
insinuated mihawk taught
zoro how to make his blade black like
his so
i'll be interested to see how that
manifests in the future for zoro however
at the end of the day this battle while
massively significant
pitting the two second strongest
fighters from each group against each
other also
offered i think more in the way of scale
and context for the battle which is
interesting because a major criticism i
had for punk hazard was how difficult it
was to understand where everyone was in
the lab relative to each other however
in this battle scenario despite it
covering a much wider area
because of contests like zoro vs pika as
long as they are on screen
we know where everyone is with him even
acting as a stepping stone for robin
rebecca and bartolomeo as they ascend
the structure to deliver
the keys to laws see prism cuffs
interweaving battles like this
made the battle itself on the island
feel even bigger and more chaotic
robin rebecca and bartolomeo with
cavendish versus gladius
this particular plotline from this
section of the battle is another
indication that odin knows
exactly what he's doing acting as a
delivery mission robin rebecca and
bartolomeo need to deliver the keys to
the seepers and cops that are trapping
law
which as a quick aside law being grumpy
towards luffy because he can't do
anything all the while luffy carries him
through treacherous passageways and
perilous climbs was something i never
knew i needed in my life
it's hilarious and offers much needed
levity to this section of the story but
moreover robin rebecca and bartolomeo
once they nab the ability to jump high
using these dandelions from the tantatas
and leaffrog their way over pika thanks
to zorro
they find themselves on this plateau
still levels behind luffy in law
facing off against gladius easily the
most edgelord looking character design
in this arc and perhaps the whole series
rebecca and robin are sent on ahead
while bartolomeo proves what he's made
of alongside cavendish
who also finds himself on the plateau
battling alongside bartolomeo and it's
moments like this that we find the
strengths of the tournament setting from
the first half of this arc starting to
take full effect the significance of
these tournament arcs for me and shonen
have less to do with the actual battles
usually and more so the story
specifically with the character growth
and character introductions that take
place
oftentimes acting as the perfect spot to
establish new
faces to better utilize them much later
in the story and right here in the
battle against gladios we experienced
that with the two most developed
characters from the tournament the
self-absolved and troubled cavendish as
well as the obsessive and goodwill
bartolomeo and during this battle all of
their traits are on full display
bartolomeo prioritizing the safety of
his idols with cavendish focusing
on the attacking aspect each one
reprimanding the other for their choice
of tactics with a significant moment
causing cavendish to begin slipping into
his akuba
form attacking with reckless abandon
while this form acts as a significant
speed and power boost for cavendish
which
would be a good thing it also adds the
extra stipulation of him losing control
cutting through anyone in his way friend
or foe
but thankfully that isn't an issue for
robin to deal with and through some
clever tactics with bartolomeo and
cavendish seeing eye tai and ultimately
switching battle strategies
cavendish taking the defensive approach
carrying robin to safety and bartolomeo
taking on the offensive
it's a neat sequence of events
culminating in a nice victory and the
ultimate progression of the team
delivering the key itself
[Music]
frankie versus senor pink now of course
with all this super serious mission type
stuff serving as the backdrop and tone
for each encounter so far
frankie vs senor pink was exactly the
sort of hard-boiled lighthearted and
intensely funny altercation
we and oda needed to cut to in order to
create greater contrast with the more
serious
moments i think something easily
forgotten in storytelling is the need
for
lulls in the action the excitement we
get and experience in an action sequence
is only exciting because
of the sudden and easily recognizable
escalation of
energy and stakes because an action
sequence often times exemplifies a
higher bar than the norm
excitement happens as a result however
if all the story ended up being was
serious fighting then the bar wouldn't
ever change and thus
quite quickly it would become stagnant
and boring so that's why in this section
of the story i am most interested by how
oda manages to create a good pace and
level of interest in this section by
creating significantly different and
strange fight scenes
and thus enter senor pink a chubby
half-naked middle-aged man sucking on a
pacifier wearing sunglasses
styling a baby's bonnet and the best
part is
his demeanor his fighting style and his
dialogue
all its appearance in such a stark way i
immediately fell in love with him
finding it additionally hilarious that
the chorus of girls following him around
everywhere are equally as taken by this
suave specimen of hard-boiled manliness
as i was what i appreciated from the
battle was once again how it informed
other conflicts and led to other
interactions the consequences of this
fight between frankie and senor pink
leads to the tantata's escape and
ultimately this is how robin rebecca and
bartolomeo come to receive these weird
dandelions in the first place that
helped them scale pika
so i may be going through these fights
sequentially but make no mistake
they are all taking place in real time
and more often than not
are messy as other people and other
fights suddenly become connected and
intertwined but more specifically with
this battle we get to enjoy a flashback
of the origin of senior pink which
was significantly more tragic than i
thought it was going to be
demonstrating a much younger man falling
in love with a woman named lucian who in
particular detests pirates
in an effort to not lose the love of his
life he manages to keep this reality
hidden from her claiming to be a banker
instead
together they have a child but
unfortunately the child dies and in
trying to contact pink his wife finds
out that he never worked at the bank he
comes clean about his piracy
causing her to run off later he
discovers that in her fleeing from him
she falls victim to a massive landslide
leaving her in a vegetative state to
this date senior ping still wears this
ridiculous outfit because
while he was caring for his wife this
was the only way he could make her
smile i mean no wonder he's so
hard-boiled but also gleaned through
these flashbacks we learned that senor
pink has been part of the don quixote
family for well over 10 years
giving us glimpses at the unit that they
were back then showing us a person or
two we might not yet have seen
regardless the battle ends in favor of
frankie but not until senor ping gives
him
everything he's got both men ultimately
vowed to not dodge and take everything
the other person has to offer
in the end only frankie was left
standing
[Music]
i want to thank surfsharkvpn for
sponsoring today's video
in the ocean of online content there's a
lot of websites that take your info
without you even knowing it but you can
swim under their radar using
surfsharkvpn with this particular
service you can stop websites from
tracking your info and selling targeted
ads to you online
completely protecting your privacy
nothing is creepier than when you have a
conversation with a friend about
something and it pops up in your ads
plus with surfshark hardlock id
protection you'll even get an alert when
some rando jerk is trying to break into
your email but one of my personal
favorite features of surfshark is that
you can see content that's not available
in your area
for instance did you know that right now
on netflix you can have the first 130
episodes of one piece well
if you live in a country where that's
not available you can just log in with
surfshark and you can get access to that
or
any other show or film that isn't
normally available for you
so if you want both freedom and
protection online click the link in the
description and use code tnm it not only
gives you a whopping 83
off the regular price but also three
months of service
totally for free surf shark also offers
a 30 30-day money-back guarantee so
there's no risk to even try it out for
yourself
so if this service sounds interesting to
you or you want to support the channel
please
check it out now back to the video
usopp the godlike sniper and speaking of
each fight in some shape or form being
connected
this one is connected more directly than
any of the others and
what's funny is that this involves
virtually no fighting but it's still my
favorite part of this section
simply because of the stakes it has and
the means with which its events are
carried out you see
once usa finds out that sugar the person
who scares him more than anyone else on
the planet apparently has reawakened
thanks to vyolo's devil fruit that
allows her to see anywhere around the
island
she sees sugar making a beeline for
luffy as they edge their way closer to
doflamingo but what makes this
interesting
is that ustop and them are the only ones
that can warn luffy
and ko about sugar's impending arrival
and what's more is that
luffy and law have no idea that she has
these powers
which means they are doomed if usopp who
is on the other side of the island
doesn't do something soon and thus are
the circumstances that set the scene for
one of the single greatest usop moments
in this series that i've witnessed
so here it goes usop has to while still
injured in fatigues from the last battle
he had
set up his mega slingshot aim using a
telescope as well as the guidance of
viola to fire a projectile and island's
length away
with pinpoint precision taking into
account the battles going on all around
the wind speed the weight of the
projectile and the secondary launchers
that are attached to the projectile
while it flies towards its destination
that needs to hit mind you
through a window at a specific part of
it did you get all that
me neither but you know what usopp
freaking did and he nails sugar not with
anything to cause her harm but to again
scare her into a comatose state using an
imitation mock-up of his scary face
using the devil fruit ability of the
other samurai who was also found just
now
it's all happening and super creative
but it wasn't enough
we also get some really cool indication
that usopp finally is tapping into some
hockey power of his own
good for him i love this scene and in
keeping with the title usop's sniper
work in this section was nothing short
of godlike
law and luffy versus doflamingo now this
is the big fight and as such it is
significantly longer with a litany of
other bells and whistles tagged onto it
to help it rise to the occasion the
first thing i noticed about this fight
that set it apart from all the others
was that it was a 2v2 battle treble and
doflamingo versus luffy and the newly
uncuffed trafalgar law
now this fight pretty much has
everything a number of dramatic saves
illuminating flashbacks increasingly
dire circumstances and a villain that
quite literally becomes a monster in a
much more conventional sense by the end
of it from top to bottom the fight
contains everything i wanted from a
final fight sequence
and while i loved it one aspect i
thought made it a 9 out of 10 instead of
a 10 out of 10 was that throughout this
act we were faked out a crazy amount of
times by way of doflamingo's body
doubles
now i acknowledge that this choice
creates this feeling that doflamingo is
always composed and one step ahead of
everyone and when that composer shatters
he becomes the string tentacle monster
tearing dressrosa to shreds
at the end and it creates a nice
contrast and i like that contrast and
progression more so than most villains
in any arc of one piece i love that his
entire motivation for years was to work
under the radar but by the end of
dealing with luffy he is as high-profile
bad guy as it gets
but in saying that by the time the real
doflamingo came to dance
i had felt like i was seeing something i
already saw and
thus the pacing for this particular
fight felt dragged out more so than
anything else in this arc
not to say i didn't like it i really did
but just slightly less than the rest
some of my favorite moments include
luffy stopping doflamingo's foot with
his own when law uses his own severed
limb to take out treble
and finally the sadistic battle
doflamingo forces bellamy to have
against luffy
while tragic this scene went a long way
in putting over doflamingo as the bad
guy of this arc if it wasn't abundantly
clear already and to be honest when
taking into account the entire story of
one piece he has to be one of the
absolute best
maybe just behind crocodile for me and i
think that's primarily down to the
liberal use of his devil fruit ability
turning everything effectively into
strings he uses it for everything
sometimes things that are almost
unbelievable using even strings to fix
his internal organs which i feel you'd
have to have some sort of medical or
surgical background in order to pull off
effectively
now to make things clear i like this
progression in devil fruit abilities it
shows that there's way more inventive
ways of using a particular power i just
found it slightly more difficult to
suspend my disbelief when dealing with
doflamingo swinging off the clouds in
dressrosa than i did with crocodile's
abilities in alabasta
i realize it might sound like i'm
knocking doflamingo here but i'm really
not i love the guy and what he offered
this arc was spectacular specifically
when this happened i thought this choice
was
fantastic and i adored this section for
the same reasons i loved alabasta it
required every relevant character to
work together towards a greater goal
just because luffy is the main character
doesn't mean the rest of them need to
wait on him to save the day they all
need to work together specifically in
this crazy situation which we again see
the straw hats work together alongside
fujitora who recognizes the madman
doflamingo is but something tells me
this was sort of his plan
but i'm not entirely certain all the
relevant moments that piqued my interest
during this arc were the flashback
scenes concerning doflamingo and
trafalgar law
exploring their respective paths and the
circumstances wherein they joined forces
and ultimately split ways
and that division was largely due to a
man called
it's a sad story but the main takeaway
from it is that the up up fruit's main
most significant power is that it can
grant someone immortality which
makes me wonder if something like that
has been proven then there must be
someone out there who is immortal
after having been granted by the op-op
fruit in the past at some point which
means
there's a distinct possibility that that
person lived through the void sentry and
therefore has all the information on it
boom i just cracked the whole thing wide
open i also learned about doflamingo's
family and where they came from which is
sounding more and more like an alien
planet considering doflamingo reiterates
that he isn't human but a god
and finally law's full name is trafalgar
d
water law i have no idea what to make of
this but sengoku who is also in this arc
seems to know more about the will of d
than anyone else i've seen so far but
fails to share it but that's for later
regardless when we get back to the
action the fight continues
only with one difference it sort of gets
turned up again
this was really cool to watch unfold on
the page before me
specifically because you know this form
hits super hard and you know that
doflamingo is really feeling it as he
gets thrashed around by this hulking
bouncing ironclad facade that this form
boasts
i'm not a massive fan of how it looks
but outside of that i do love how it
shakes things up
and changes the tension of the scene
specifically when it leaves luffy
completely drained of energy and
defenseless after using it
once again bringing significance and
urgency to the supporting cast to
protect him
reinforcing that everyone in this arc
serves their own purpose and it's
absolutely clear that a ton of care and
effort went into establishing every
single one of them from the relationship
and fights that kiros and rebecca
partake in for each other to the
obsession both cavendish
and bartilla mayo share for luffy to the
love and trust each and every one of the
straw hats has for each other
nothing in this arc goes to waste and
it's all explored and made use of in
this closing scene specifically
with everyone working together to buy
luffy enough time to recover in order to
deal the finishing blow
unfortunately as fate would have it as
doflamingo rampages through the city
he manages to get a hold of rebecca and
viola puppeteering her and trying to
force her into killing her own sister
thankfully someone interjects
there are a lot of visual and thematic
components to the story of dressrosa
that share parallels and contrast well
with
similarly to alabasta we are aiding the
princess of a particular region in an
effort to save her kingdom from the main
villain who wishes to gain control over
it for his ulterior motives
we have a largely group oriented battle
requiring everyone to fight before all
working together at the end to buy
luffy as much time as possible in
addition to that the significance of
luffy's role is brought about by some
visual components also
in the case of alabasa it was the reign
to signify the end of battle and in this
instance it's the vanishing of the
birdcage
i think this format works specifically
well for oda and the ensemble cast of
characters he's assembled within these
pages
however obviously in saying that there
are plenty of aspects to this tale that
make it unique into and of itself
the main standout being the inclusion of
law who on more than one occasion
throws a wrench into the works of
doflamingo's plan by either protecting
luffy during the latter stages or more
specifically when he manages to get his
hands on doflamingo and deals a near
fatal blow to him which
by the way was amazing something of
interest i also noticed was the activity
of jesus burgess in dissection through
his engagement and entanglement with
sabo he seems to be hell-bent on still
extracting the devil fruit powers from
him and the battle that ensues is
satisfying or at least i thought it was
i love the flame flame fruit it's just
my favorite but to be honest even after
having split this arc in two
covering all the intricacies of these
battles will almost always be a losing
effort for me i never even touched on
the incredibly touching battle kiros had
against diamante in the place of rebecca
with help from robin in the flower field
this battle really reinforces who kiros
is where his values lie
and even what he thinks of himself which
manifests in the conclusion with him
trying to distance himself from rebecca
as he felt he didn't deserve to be her
father however thanks to the help of
luffy who went out of his way to help
this situation he allows rebecca to
catch up to kiros before he bails
entirely and the scene is a mucus-filled
emotional high point of the story for
sure oh and by the way
this ending to dressrosa is like super
long and i don't mean that it was boring
it's just that it contains again so much
stuff like a retired sengoku who has now
retired and is boasting a head full of
white hair
it's so refreshing to see sengoku laugh
about the situation fujitora has elected
to let them fall to
allowing the straw hats to regroup
roaring the dice every day for such a
thing to be allowed but the most
important action fujitora takes during
this entire section
is seen at the very end of the battle
when he purposely bows before the entire
country and world
asking for forgiveness in failing the
entire country
essentially apologizing on behalf of the
navy and preventing them from spinning
their own narrative like they did in
alabasta giving credit to smoker
which he acknowledges from afar and i
really appreciated that inclusion from
smoker too okay all that aside
it's time to discuss the most important
change this arc granted the series
so as luffy and the crew retreat to the
docks while being pursued by
admiral fujitora something curious
happens a real sign of changed times and
progression
luffy flat out refuses to run any longer
and dukes it out with fujitora exciting
that things are different and aren't all
like they were in the past he's now an
extremely powerful pirate
and has no need to run any longer it's
also here that i learned that fujitora
can't summon meteors from random places
but instead pulls large amounts of rock
and rubble to the ground
which gave me a bit of a brainwave
fujitora's pull is far-reaching right
the first
instance is demonstrated to us as he
pulls a meteor from space it looks like
which
could mean technically if he's powerful
enough he could
in theory pull the moon down to earth
which houses nl from the skypia arc
it's just a thought but i'm calling it
here that's totally going to happen in
some shape or form in the future
it absolutely seems like the crazy type
of thing oda would totally do
and for fun here's another theory i had
while reading fujitora has the ability
to pull things down towards the earth
and
we've seen him use these dice multiple
times in this arc
my theory is that maybe he can control
the number that dice rolls to
using his devil fruit power in doing so
he controlled the fade of the dice rolls
perhaps in order to let luffy recover
but
he might have also used this power as a
means of testing luffy's honor at the
beginning of this arc
it's just a thought
[Music]
but the aspect that made this arc a
masterpiece was the inclusion of this
scene at the very end
where all the warriors we've come to
know over the course of this arc pledged
their lives and services to luffy and
the straw hats
essentially this is the moment where
luffy gains the power of an armada 5
600 men strong now the reason why i
found this to be extremely impressive
was
first of all i never saw this coming but
the means with which oda makes this work
was again extremely subtle and efficient
typically the tournament arc setting
grants a writer the ability to introduce
a bunch of different people
establish their characters and offers
interesting matchups that explore the
nature
and abilities of each individual which
is essentially character development in
fast forward
and this was useful in the traditional
sense during this arc when we were able
to utilize characters like cavendish and
bartolomeo as well as the rest of them
in crucial scenarios that even carried
some of the narrative tension and weight
but
when i saw this scene i realized that he
used the tournament setting and this arc
to set up and establish quite well i
might add the foundations that make up
the captains of luffy's armada
while reading through this story a few
weeks back i realized that there would
of course come eventually a time in the
not so distant future
where luffy would require such forces
but i always wondered how it would be
done
i figured these characters would need to
be established independently and over
the course of the series
luffy would acquire them similar to how
he did with the original straw hat
pirates
but instead he completely surprises me
by getting the entire thing in one
instance while also taking me completely
by surprise imagine if you will
being surprised by the natural inclusion
of a 5
600 man strong armada and i was blown
away by how he pulled it off here
in essence there's tons of fallout to
this arc kids alliance is after setting
their eyes on shanks
the alliance oukiji made with blackbeard
seems to have after falling through the
rest of the straw hats are after
arriving on some strange island
while also being pursued by something
and most importantly
we finally get our first glimpse of
kaido leaping from the sky island in an
effort to kill himself
a ridiculously impossible feat which
makes him all the more imposing and
impressive to see
and finally all the straw hats now have
new bounties luffy's has been up to 500
million zoro finally got some respect on
his new bounty at 320 million the most
surprising is us who now
has his real face on it for the world to
see at 200 million but
by far the single most interesting thing
brought to my attention is sanji's
bounty
well after being raised specifically
requests that he
be captured alive while the others be
captured dead or alive
i'm not sure what this means maybe he
has an important extended family or
something either way
something to do with sanji is incredibly
important considering everything he's
done and yet they insist on his live
capture the next stop on our voyage is
zo and lord knows what i'll find there
but i am nevertheless extremely excited
to see
what the story has still in store for me
but that'll do it for this video
i've been totally not mark i'll see you
all next week and thank you so much for
watching
so